les amis on parle maintenant de florence
foresti parce que sur twitter c'est un
déferlement depuis conduit cette info
sur florence foresti vous le savez ou
pas elle interdit les téléphones
portables durant son prochain spectacle
en gros quand on a même un ennemi qui a
voulu aller sur spectacle donc vous
recevez un mail pour ou dans le show
passion née ici en bon titre ou pas ou
vous dit dans le même que voilà les
téléphones portables sont interdits
en gros vous arrivé là bas si vous
refusez de donner votre portable vous
n'êtes pas autorisés dans la pièce et si
vous acceptez de données on le met dans
un sac qui va être scellé que vous aurez
avec vous et donc il ne pourra pas sonné
pendant toute la durée du spectacle si
vraiment il ya une urgence
vous pouvez prendre le sac et est dans
une pièce où le sac va être ouvert et
vous pourrez répondre au téléphone
est-ce que ça choque est-ce que ça
choque pas voilà ce qui qui le prend la
parole oui c'est hyper chaud quand on
puisse on va à l'encontre des libertés
là c'est n'importe quoi
moi ce que je trouve et je suis déjà
allé voir des comédiens ils font un
petit sketch au début de manière très
sympathique et très drôle mais en
remettant les points sur les i en disant
voilà vous sortez pas vos portables et
tout et on peut le faire de manière
humoristique
apparemment les gens gardent leurs
téléphones avec mais délègue pas ce qui
peut montrer le mail ici on a le mail
qu'on reçoit voilà ce qu'on montre assez
rarement il est ce qu parce qu'on ait
personne qui essayait de passer le mail
que vous recevez ici voilà pour eux
puisque elle va jouer bientôt un zénith
de paris je vais un peu de pub des
débits descendants du 26 au 31 décembre
aux in de paris abbas était très rapide
à tvo ses macintosh vous vous lisez
comme ça je ne le crois pas mais si vous
l'avez lu vous me le dites est ce que ça
vous choque ou pas voilà vous démarquer
ici donc vous êtes prévenus il ya un
côté un mois je me méfie un peu j'ai
même peur peur qu'un jour quelqu'un
arrive et que ça finisse mal sûr que si
vous refusez qu on vous sort avec 15
avec un videur comment ça se passe juste
un mot mathieu est la raison pour béja à
dieu m'a choqué donc maintenant parce
que déjà tout le monde parle de son
spectacle autour de la table et je suis
super opération publique on aurait parlé
autant c'est les faibles et puis c'est
pas pareil dans le cas des conserves et
des musiciens et dans les cadets des
humoristes parce que le problème c'est
que là si tout le monde film avec un
portable vous avez toujours un rayon de
retard cerveau n'est pas concentré sur
ce qui se passe sur scène et je pense
que ça qui est qu'il en ait un petit peu
elle sent que les gens sont pas voilà
que vous n'êtes pas choqué c'est quand
même moi j'étais quand même pas
dictature mais en fait il ya quand même
un côté oui ça fait parti d'un relais
votre liberté pendant deux heures
dorénavant il n'y a pas de portable on
était pas moins libres nous voulons
c'est un système de communication j'ai
un choc et de myriam non mais en fait ce
qui se cache derrière ça c'est pas
savoir si les gens suivent suivent leur
spectacle ou pas c'est juste qu'ils
veulent pas que ça se retrouve sur
youtube ou ailleurs et que du coup ils
vous vendent moins leur leur dvd à la
fin du mois d'août fabien comprenait
aussi ce qu'elle dit aussi voir si vous
réussissez la raison ça sonne pendant
que tu es un sketch d'argent et c'est
juste une question d'éducation il faut
mettre son téléphone hors champ c'est
moi j'ai des enfants j'ai pas envie d'y
jouer non pas comme un lecteur de dvd
c'est pas pour ça qu'elle fait ça c'est
la plus grosse baisse dvd en bas c'est
pour mes erreurs alors attendez brouille
il ya il ya des brouilleurs si on est
des bons skieurs plutôt que d'empêcher
des gens non avoir axé leur téléphone
c'est juste pour protéger et d'une
exhaustivité des images mais bien sûr
tout sinon et dvd les plus vendus sont
ceux qui sont plus filmer et forcément
une corrélation scolaire sur youtube
c'est larry reçoit des mails et moi j'ai
beaucoup d'amis comme et des hameaux
leurs expressions faciales d'avignon et
tout ils sont super g n'est laurentiis
les portables bruit des portables parce
que commencer oui si catherine catherine
catherine juste un mot juste pour
répondre brouilleurs les brouilleurs la
question a été posée aux équipes de
force foresti les brouilleurs c'est un
vrai problème parce qu'en cas d'un tenta
aussi a vraiment une urgence mais on ne
veut pas du coup j'en à personne alors
que là s'il ya une urgence
on peut avec son sac aller quelque part
et le sac est ouvert et on peut on peut
voir que téléphone a sonné s'il ya une
urgence
donc ça marche pas le cas mais j'ai une
petite info part dans une petite info en
fait aux états vont tester ce système là
et il ya quand même eu des problèmes
c'est à dire que ça ça n'a pas marché
et puis surtout ils ont testé aussi pour
le à londres omar sy spectacle harry
potter absolument et en fait ça n'a pas
marché donc elle n'est pas sûr que ça
marche
tous les téléphones se sont mis à sonner
en même temps tous à ce que peuvent vous
embrouiller commencer un bug ça a été un
beau mais c'est quand même problématique
mais ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il paraît
qu aux états unis pour l'instant ils le
font pas encore parce que c'est pas
encore militaires encore au point il
viendrait de la tester way we delphine
oui moi je trouve vous oubliez vous
payez votre place pour vous détendre
passer un bon moment et l'a directement
on vous dit ban on le porte à machin
chose ça fait mauvaise ambiance bon sur
une soirée qui est censé être partout
montréal au cinéma au cinéma tapas le
pen aurait même
les gens mais ça va se discipliner tu
leur expliques mais de là à leur prend
le portable ces mots valeurs sûres
attention ma gueule c'est une honte non
mais vraiment c'est honteux parce
qu'elle ne respecte pas ses fans quand
elle fait ça y est les gens qui font des
économies pour aller voir un spectacle
moi j'ai quand j'étais jeune j'allais
voir johnny hallyday en spectacle j'ai
les images parce que je vais filmer avec
mon téléphone c'est pour moi un des plus
beaux souvenirs de ma vie et je trouve
que c'est pas respecté ses fans de leur
genre ces souvenirs
j'entends mais si les fans la respecte
quand ça sonne et puis comment vit à 30
ans pardon d'enfants malades mourraient
pas pendant deux heures on au 21ème
siècle
en tout cas moi j'en bois de florence
foresti un succès important de respecter
les artistes monter seule une fois sur
scène bon jamais faire mais j'imagine
que c'est très difficile